alright Gilmore Girls listen up the
highly anticipated Netflix revival is
officially out and we have some major
stars hollow secrets to discuss but if
you have not watched yet or do not want
to be spoiled about the major plot
points or those last four words leave
now I'm serious because we're about to
spill it all in three in the spring
episode of Gilmore Girls Rory and Karis
return to Chilton for alumni day but we
were shocked to see that bad boy Tristan
de Grey who was originally played by
Chad Michael Murray was replaced by a
different actor that's right
Days of Our Lives star Anton Mariinsky
took on the role were you surprised that
they couldn't get Chad Michael Murray
there were prizes tristin yeah I mean it
would have been nice but he's busy he's
doing a lot of things he's doing very
well for himself Chad Michael Murray so
I think at all you know I think it plays
a quick shot very very quick shot yeah
and yeah I mean there's a lot going on
well um that day but it was it was I was
I was so glad that we were able to
revisit Chilton and and it and it really
did make so much sense to me
psychologically I could see that that
would be a big trigger for Paris
Oh